some of you are going through at this
hmm
at this exact moment the toughest time
of your life either the brokest you've
ever been the scare dish you've ever
been the most hopeless you've ever been
it's hard I was 24 years old I start
buying and selling real estate by the
time I was 26 starting from nothing I
had about 4 million dollars with a real
estate a little over a million dollar
net worth and I made $250,000 cash
taxable income that year that's $20,000
a month the neighborhood I grew up in in
1986 we called that rich but I had done
a lot of stupid stuff in that I had
borrowed money out my ears the bank
called our notes and we spent the next
two and a half years of our life losing
everything we owned I filed bankruptcy
in September Rachel was born in April
right before that so I had a brand-new
baby a toddler and a marriage hanging on
by a thread August before I filed in
September I was sitting in my recliner
because I couldn't sleep at 3:30 4
o'clock in the morning reading my Bible
and the words off the page came alive
rejoice in your suffering and I looked
up at God and I said no I'm not gonna
rejoice in my suffering that's just
weird
rejoice in your suffering this suffering
produces perseverance and perseverance
character character
hope and hope is a gift of the Holy
Spirit that may be where some of you are
right now you know it's almost
impossible to rejoice in your suffering
I mean really that is just weird
it's a weird request of God speaking in
His Word and I'd like to tell you I did
I got up and did a little jig and I
rejoiced in my suffering but I didn't
all I did was just say that's weird but
it produces perseverance and it did do
that and that produced character and it
did do that and he gave me hope which
I've never lost 30 years later you see
my plan was to become worth a few
million dollars owning real estate God
says I have plans for you and they're
not to give you not to bring you harm
but to give you hope and I think what he
was telling me that morning when I was
sitting there and he may be talking to
you right this second is your little
dinky plans weren't much my little dinky
plans to have a couple million dollars
in real estate that my heavenly father's
crazy about me and he had a much bigger
plan for my life mmm obviously we've got
a lot more a few million dollars for the
real estate now and that's not how we
measure it though think about the impact
that this Ramsey organization in this
message with this radio show on 600
stations and the fifth-largest podcast
in the world the number of lives and the
richness of soul and satisfaction that
God has given us around this place as we
help people everywhere all over the
world all because I was stupid and went
bankrupt
my little dinky plan my father had so
much better plan for me
the
my little dinky plan I know some of your
hurting and scared right now it could be
that you're getting ready to substitute
your best plan your shiniest plan you're
gonna look back later and like I am and
it has a dinky plan that wasn't much of
a plan it could be that God's saying you
ain't seen nothing yet
you hear all these people out there
right now walking around going well
there's a new normal things will never
be the same like Eeyore is their spirit
animal oh it's bad and so now there's a
new normal is always gonna be rough
we're always gonna have Corona hanging
around life is gonna be bad I don't know
how we're gonna make it you hearing
these whiners out there they're
everywhere I don't think life is gonna
return to what it was I think it's gonna
be better
because some of you are having a never
again moment some of you your dinky
little plans have gotten set aside
because God has a bigger plan for you
you ain't seen nothing yet now you may
not like that message and that's okay
you can get your own show this is the
Dave Ramsey show